- Today's mission is to
intentionally get stuck in traffic.
Check this out, complete standstill.
I've actually really outdone myself here.
Been here for about five minutes.
Fun.
Inner city traffic can
be a real nightmare.
A great way to spend a hot Thursday.
In New York City, the traffic is so bad
that the MTA estimates New
Yorkers lose an average
of 117 hours in congestion each year.
But here in London and in Singapore,
we have a thing called congestion tolls
that aims to reduce traffic
by charging drivers to enter
busier parts of the city.
And now congestion tolls
are headed to New York.
- It's gonna be implemented
in about a year.
We're actually installing
the infrastructure,
all the cameras and the sensors right now.
- But here's the thing,
even though there's a congestion charge
in London and has been for
decades, I'm still stuck
in traffic and the roads have
actually been getting slower.
So do congestion tolls work?
How will New York use them?
And are these cameras
headed for other US cities?
Let's find out.
So here's how it works.
London's congestion charge zone covers
around eight square miles in the center
of the city and the boundaries delineated
by these red circles on
the road and these signs.
I've just crossed over the
congestion charge boundary zone
where I will be picked up by some cameras
that are just up there that
will register my license plate
and charge me 15 pounds to drive
in the zone for the day,
which is around $19.
It's not actually me that'll
be charged, it's my wife
'cause it's all linked to her account.
Sorry, darling.
So what's New York's congestion
charge going to look like?
- There you are.
- How you doing? Nice to meet you.
- How you doing?
- [George] To answer that,
here's Metropolitan
Transportation Authority CEO,
Janno Lieber.
- All of Manhattan, south of 60th Street,
which is just at the
bottom of Central Park,
is going to in effect be a tolled area.
There are two marginal
highways on the west
and east side of the island
of Manhattan where you
can circumvent the toll.
We think the price is gonna be somewhere
between 10 and maybe 20 bucks
and the tolls are gonna
automatically appear
on people's E-ZPasses.
- The MTA told me it was
still finalizing pricing
but it was considering
discounts and tax credits
for low income frequent
drivers and residents.
It also told me it would
monitor traffic levels
around the congestion zone to try
and avoid a buildup
from people avoiding it.
Where will the congestion
charge money be going?
- It has to be used to improve
the mass transit system
but we're not just
maintaining what we have.
We're building, extending subway lines.
With climate change
and the air quality issues
that all cities are facing,
there's really no choice.
- The MTA says that 80% of the money
will be used to improve New York's Subways
and buses while 10% each will be going
to the Long Island Railroad
and Metro North Railroad.
But implementing a congestion
toll can be pretty divisive.
After all, these tolls
are designed to make one
of the most convenient forms
of transport a financial inconvenience.
The MTA has already received requests
from over 100 different groups
that believe they should
be exempt or discounted
from the toll, from
musicians to hearse drivers.
- We have even the farmers have claimed
that they should not be charged.
There are a lot of good stories out there
but the bottom line is,
in the United States,
we don't have a history of
exempting people from tolls.
- But the loudest critic
of New York's plan has been New Jersey.
See, folks driving from New Jersey
into New York already pay between 14
and $17 in tolls when they
use these bridges and tunnels.
New Jersey officials have said
an additional congestion toll
would unfairly burden New Jersey commuters
and that a fuller
environmental impact study
should be conducted.
It then sued the Department
of Transportation.
- New Jersey's actually
initiated a lawsuit
against the federal government
for approving our plan.
And the governor of New York
State has said, respectfully,
pound sand, this is going to happen.
- So if it's going to happen, can it work?
Can congestion tolls make roads faster?
Well, New York's plan is
yet to get off the ground
but London's has been in
place for around two decades.
So I went to Transport for London, or TFL,
the government body responsible
for London's transport networks,
kinda like the city's
equivalent of the MTA.
Here's Alina Tuerk.
Are they effective?
- Yes, they are effective.
We found that when we first
introduced the charge,
traffic entering the zone dropped
by 18% and congestion dropped by 30%.
- But the problem is London's
roads didn't stay that way.
- Over time, congestion levels
have started to go up again.
- TFL data shows that from 2010 to 2019,
the average speed in
central London got slower
from nine miles an hour to
seven, and delays increased
from around 1.5 minutes per
kilometer to around 2.5.
So what's going on?
Why am I still stuck in traffic?
Well, even though some
drivers can choose to switch
to a city's public transport network,
others, like for hire vehicles
and delivery drivers, can't.
And the number of those drivers
has increased over the years.
Over 50% of the vehicles
in Manhattan's proposed
congestion tolling area
are for hire vehicles and taxis.
Many cities have also
reallocated road space
to buses, bikes, and pedestrians.
- There's now also less
road space available,
hence that balancing out
with the congestion levels.
- But even if congestion zones
don't always make roads quicker,
they can have other benefits.
One is that they can reduce emissions.
TFL say that CO2 emissions
in London have fallen by some
one million tons since 2010
in part due to the congestion zone.
But another is that they can
be very good at raising money,
whether that was the intended plan or not.
- It's not a money-making scheme
or it hasn't got a
revenue-raising objective,
but nevertheless, it
does make a net surplus.
(tranquil music)
(door slamming)
- So with congestion
charging seeming destined
for US streets,
does that mean we're
going to start seeing it
across other cities in the US?
Well, Janno hopes so.
- I not only think it could work,
I know that other cities are watching
what we're doing closely.
- Cities from LA to Seattle
have been discussing
whether systems like this
could be used to alleviate
their traffic issues.
And in London.
- We are getting a lot of interest,
a lot of inquiries from
cities all around the world.
- So keep an eye on New York.
While its congestion toll
will likely be the very first
in America, it might not be the last.
(lively music)